- He's an Indian composer,
singer-songwriter
and music producer.
In a notable two-decade long plus career,
he's been credited with redefining
the contemporary Indian
music film industry.
His body of work for film
and stage has earned him
the nickname as the
Mozart of his industry.
He's A.R. Rahman
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down the comments below,
put quotes around them as well
so other people can be inspired.
Also, when you write it down
you're much more likely to lock
it in for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(electronic wind blowing)
(electronic slamming)
(upbeat music)
(beeping)
(electronic wind)
- What is modern is
rediscovering yourself,
rediscovering the way music is done
is modern.
I do love to embrace new technology and
new ideas.
And especially like in
the film, like Slum Dog,
where Danny suggested am I someone
in operation of music and everything.
So it was like two
cultures meeting in a way.
Like some of the people
who are very close-minded
say oh what are they
doing, it's just noise.
Rap is noise and heavy metal is noise.
So when you go into that
frame of just try to
like something for what
it is, not, you know,
go take a lens and
disrupt it and try and analyze it.
So with this philosophy, I think
I kept moving on for like eight years.
Rediscovering myself.
Music has given me everything.
Respect, Oscars, Grammys and you know,
love and money and fame and everything.
So I'm into it.
I would rather sit in a room, do my music
and pray and then sleep
and that's my kind of.
But it how pushed me
to become this person,
a founder of a Conservatory,
is these incidents.
And after you've become 40
you see that you're hitting a wall.
You're seeing that you're
going towards death.
Which is the question
which pushes many people to
start doing many things because
of the fear of not living.
I mean, I didn't have a fear,
but I was fearless
because of that in a way.
So even if I fail in this attempt
of doing this music
education thing, that's fine.
I've tried something nice and I'd failed.
(slamming)
- Your success has been
dramatic, obviously
and coming from a city
like Chennai, of course
culturally very rich we are
in our state of Tamil Nadu,
but more importantly to be
able to go global with that
has been just quite
awe-inspiring to be honest.
And made all of us so
proud here in Chennai.
But if you look at young musicians today
and what they are being offered,
and the technology, it's
moved along as well.
What would you say to them?
- I think they have to
find their own voice.
They found their own inner voice.
The moment we try to do somebody else's
we become mediocre.
We want to be try,
our limitations are sometimes our plusses.
So sometime that forces
you to think in a way where
there are many millions
of ways to achieve a song,
achieve greatness
in art.
So you find a different way,
you don't have to,
you know, a classic
example is Kumar Gandharva,
the classical singer.
He had a lung problem
or something like that
so he couldn't sustain his notes.
If you listen to his rendering,
he would just make everything short.
♫ Ah
He wouldn't like
♫ Ah.
He would never sustain it
because of his breathing problem
But that became a great style.
You don't have to copy that
because his limitation became
a style of what he could amazingly do
when it was unique when he sang.
So I think all of us have limitations
and we should not think it's a limitation.
So there's something else which is there,
a plus within you
and then bring that out.
And then you become totally different.
- Surely in the past,
you must have been criticized by people.
And sometimes people say
some really harsh things.
How do you deal with that criticism
and what advice will you give
to other musicians out there
facing that?
- You have to
elevate yourself to be
the harshest critic.
And when that comes
so you supersede every other critic.
And you become a better
critic than everybody else.
You wouldn't be bothered because
the criticism which comes
you've already done it to yourself
and you can say, yeah, I
know that, I'm working on it
in your mind.
When there's a tough
situation in your life,
consider this idea.
Slow down your mind, detach
yourself from sadness,
and always be bold to walk the path.
You will certainly find relief, solutions,
breakthrough ideas and
extraordinary rewards.
But do not expect them soon.
They will come to you at the right time
because if rewards come too soon,
you will not be able to handle it
and it could be a recipe for disaster.
- What is your advice and
motivation for young people
who want to pursue a career in music?
With what amount of knowledge and content
does one break through?
- I feel whatever,
first of all, you need
to have a ear for music.
You need to love beautiful stuff,
then it becomes part of you.
- That's right.
- It's even within spirituality
or music's the same thing,
the more you start getting into something
and then it becomes you.
So if you're half-heartedly
doing something
and you don't give enough
time, it's not worth it.
And don't even think
about sustenance, nothing,
and then just go and do
it become a master of it
people will come following you.
And that's the truth.
- You know, the pressure must be enormous,
you know, oh, he's won an Academy Award,
the next time around you
were nominated for 127 Hours,
of course, but I mean
what is that feeling like
I mean it's like, you know,
when you win a major tournament
and you come back the next year,
everyone's looking to say, oh,
he's going to win it again.
Which is not the case, of course.
- Yeah, for me, I think I
made my mind realize that
you know, two is enough for your lifetime.
And if anything comes it's a bonus.
And so your mind is not
thinking about awards,
it's thinking about art.
And so that's a good thing I thought,
and I'm slowly also becoming
more familiar with visual stuff
I'm trying to create concepts.
Because after a point you have a monotony.
People in India, they
have a format of music
which is, give me five
songs, give me six songs,
I'll make a movie.
And then when you work within Broadway
and Western and everything, you feel like
how are these guys doing?
They're doing something different.
They're going more deeper into
what could be achieved,
the marriage of both.
So that forced me to,
and these long flights too,
LA from Dubai and Emirates.
I'll be thinking of how do you
take music to another
sensible place.
And it is very challenging,
and putting a challenge on yourself.
And you're burdening yourself,
but then it's totally worth it.
So I'm doing music videos now, trying to.
It's not an easy thing,
but it's keeping me engaged
and I'm learning a lot.
I cannot believe that it's over 10 years
since my music and me
have been associated
with Miami University.
I've enjoyed collaborating
with your students,
your faculty, particularly
from Team Global Rhythms
and above all,
every interaction has allowed
for greater understanding,
sensitivity and growth.
I feel humbled by the fact
that so many students here
from another culture have made
my music part of their lives.
Learning from this
experience has allowed me
to gain considerable
confidence in starting my own
Western Classical Conservatory in India.
Above all, there are several
Miami students who have come
over to assist me in making
KM Music Conservatory
grow in multiple ways,
and they have grown themselves,
learning from our culture
back in South India.
Learning through travel.
Keep an open mind, and be
ready to receive things
that come along the journey.
So often, we have an opinion
from someone or a place
or a culture before
heading to a destination.
Each one of us are made differently.
Sometimes there are many
hidden truths of a place,
that never reveal to us,
that are never revealed to us
'til we experience it ourselves.
- What for you today is the challenge.
Is it the vary of repeating yourself?
- Ultimately, it's all the same.
- Okay.
- Something is catchy,
it reaches the public.
- Right.
- Something's melodic, they recognize it.
But how can you give it
in different forms where
they don't feel like, oh, it's
the same thing for 20 years.
- Right.
- At the same time, you
know, musically explore,
even take an even more dangerous path.
Let's see what happens.
I feel the thirst to learn
is very, very important.
Even now I feel like I'm not learn enough
And when certain situations
come in, I said, Oh my God,
I should have learned music properly.
And I should have learned
counterpoint properly.
The speed is what gets affected.
You can do anything, but then
if you have a very strong mind and will,
you can do anything, but
at what speed can you do?
And also when you learn something,
it also rivets you to one kind of genre,
where you're specializing.
For me, it was, I was always learning.
So I was always moving from
thing to another thing.
So whatever fascinated me,
I kept moving.
So my music was never
rooted to one little thing,
it had a,
probably people say my style,
but then I kept moving.
(electronic wind)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Anushka asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I will see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what
did you learn from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or your business?
What was your favorite
clip of the 10, and why?
Please leave it in the comments below.
I'm super-curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout-out
to Kalie and Bradley.
Thank you guys so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting that picture.
I really love it, it means a lot to me,
I appreciate the support,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(electronic wind blowing)
(electronic slamming)
- Never rush into judgment.
Especially about people.
There always another side
of the story, a good side.
We must always find ways
to see the beauty and value
of a person or a place or an
institution or an art form.
And half the problems of each of us
can be solved if people
don't rush into judgment.
It think, like in every profession,
when you're first learning to drive,
you're like, oh, I should
keep my clutch ready,
I should put my brakes.
I mean after a point of time you just
it's so new an you know exactly,
you'll be doing multiple
things and you're driving.
So music is something like that.
Once you learn the basics
and you internalize it,
and after a point of time
it's only whether you can
connect to certain things
and focus to certain things
which they want.
Whether it's a sad song
and it's spiritual music.
Or then you get the technology out,
and the technicality out
and you just go to focus to
what do you need to achieve.
What are the combinations of
organic material you need,
like a voice or an instrument.
And what not to use, how
much less it should be,
and how much epic it should be.
So all these balances
and what kind of a tonality it should be.
Like it's sounding vintage
sounding, modern sounding.
And all these come as
an instinctive thing.
And the other difficulties gets past you.
(electronic wind blowing)